>> Tucker: TED CRUZ HAS CAST A
VOTE THAT SOME DEMOCRATS DON'T
LIKE.
RATHER THAN WAIT UNTIL THE
ELECTIONS TWO WEEKS FROM NOW TO
VOTE AGAINST HIM, SOME DECIDED
TO SCREAM AT HIM AND HIS WIFE IN
A RESTAURANT.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT PUTTING A
SEXUAL ASSAULT ON THE COURT IS A
GOOD THING FOR WOMEN?
>> GOD BLESS YOU.
>> THAT IS WHAT YOUR VOTE COST.
>> I BELIEVE IN IT DUE PROCESS
PAIRED >> WHY DO YOU SUPPORT A
MAN THAT ABUSES WOMEN?
SHAME ON YOU, TED CRUZ.
>> GOD BLESS YOU.
>> SHAME ON YOU, TED CRUZ.
>> Tucker: "SHAME ON YOU, TED
CRUZ?"
THAT WAS WASHINGTON NATIONAL
AIRPORT.
HE IS NOT THE ONLY LAWMAKER
GETTING YELLED THAT THESE DAY,
MITCH McCONNELL RECENTLY
SCREAMED AT IN A RESTAURANT,
WATCH.
>> Tucker: YOU WANT TO LIVE IN
THIS COUNTRY?
OF COURSE YOU DON'T, MOST PEOPLE
ARE HORRIFIED BY IT.
SOME PEOPLE DEFEND IT, FORMER
HILLARY AIDE SAID IT WAS A MADE
UP PROBLEM.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> I WASN'T DEFENDING TED CRUZ,
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN REPUBLICANS
CHANTING AT TED CRUZ, THE WAY HE
IS UNPOPULAR.
SCREAMING AT PEOPLE IN PUBLIC
PLACES -- IT IS NOT THE
WAY PEOPLE SHOULD BEHAVE,
EDITION NOT ANYTHING WE SHOULD
DEFENDANT IS NOT THE COUNTRY
WANT TO LIVE IN, IS IT?
>> THE FIRST INSTANCE OF THIS
WAS SARAH SANDERS, WHO WAS IN A
RESTAURANT IN VIRGINIA AND WAS
EJECTED.
SHE WAS ASKED VERY NICELY TO
LEAVE.
SHE WAS ASKED NICELY MORE THAN
SOMETIMES YOU ARE NICE TO ME IN
TERMS OF QUESTIONS, SO I DO NOT
THINK THAT IS A HEAVY PRICE TO
PAY FOR SOMEONE WHO LIES WITH
IMPUNITY EVERY DAY TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: SO YOU WORK FOR
HILLARY CLINTON, WHOSE HUSBAND
WAS IN CREDIBLY ACCUSED OF RAPE
BY SOMEONE WITH ALL KINDS OF
CONTEMPORANEOUS -- BUT THAT IS
NOT WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR.
I'M JUST SAYING HE WAS ACCUSED
OF RAPE.
HIS MOTHER GAVE BIRTH TO HIM,
WHY SHOULD HE BE ALLOWED TO BE
IN A RESTAURANT?
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> NOBODY WAS PROTESTING SARAH
SANDERS MOTHERS, IT WAS SARAH
SANDERS.
>> Tucker: BECAUSE SHE WORKS
FOR A GUY SHE DOESN'T LIKE.
>> SHE DOESN'T HAVE TO WORK
THERE, SHE HAS FREE WILL, IT IS
AN HONOR AND PRIVILEGE TO WORK
THERE.
SHE CHOOSES EVERY DAY TO LIVE TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PEOPLE ARE SEEING PUBLIC
OFFICIALS, AND THEY DON'T SEE
ANY ACCOUNTABILITY.
THEY ARE THINKING TO THEMSELVES
THEMSELVES -- ELECTIONS ARE TWO
WEEKS.
AT ONE POINT IS THIS OKAY?
100 DAYS AGO -- I'M NOT THE
ANGRY MOB, 100 DAYS AGO I
STARTED A PROTEST OUTSIDE THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AS LOYAL VIEWERS KNOW THAT I
COULDN'T HURT A FLY.
DONALD TRUMP IS TRYING TO SHUT
THAT DOWN BECAUSE HE DOESN'T
WANT PROTESTERS OUTSIDE.
>> Tucker: I'M GUESSING THE
POINT I'M MAKING, IS IT OKAY,
OR DO THINGS START TO FALL APART
OR DO THINGS START TO FALL APAR-
OR DO THINGS START TO FALL APARL
OR DO THINGS START TO FALL APART
OR DO THINGS START TO FALL APARS
OR DO THINGS START TO FALL APARH
OR DO THINGS START TO FALL APARN
OR DO THINGS START TO FALL APARS
OR DO THINGS START TO FALL APARA
OR DO THINGS START TO FALL APARE
OR DO THINGS START TO FALL APAR'
OR DO THINGS START TO FALL APART
OKAY.
>> SINCE DONALD TRUMP HASN'T
BEEN SWORN IN, NOT ONE OF THOSE
DAYS HAS HE SAID WE HAVE TO DIAL
DOWN THE RHETORIC THAT I WOULD
TELL YOU WHAT HE DID SAY.
THE LAST FEW DAYS -- I WILL TELL
YOU WHAT I SAW.
HE SPECIFICALLY -- WE ARE NOT IN
POWER.
>> Tucker: NO, BECAUSE -- ALL
THE ROBOTS THAT FINALLY YOU ARE
DOING THIS.
TEN PEOPLE HAVE BEEN YELLED
AT -- ALL CONSERVATIVES.
IS THAT OKAY WITH YOU?
>> I'M OKAY WITH SARAH SANDERS,
SECRETARY NIELSEN, AND MITCH
McCONNELL.
YES, MITCH McCONNELL WAS MORE
IN DANGER OF SALMONELLA IN THAT
RESTAURANT THAN HE WAS --
>> Tucker: HILLARY CLINTON A
RESTAURANT, AND I WALK UP TO
HER -- SHE LEAVES --
>> THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
UNPLEASANT AND OKAY.
I WENT SAY PROTESTING, YOU ARE
JUST -- IF I SEPARATED CHILDREN
FROM THEIR PARENTS AND I WENT TO
DINNER AT A MEXICAN RESTAURANT,
I WOULD REALIZE --
>> Tucker: HOW ABOUT IF I
ENDORSE THIRD TERM ABORTIONS?
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS I
DISAGREE WITH, I FIND IT
REPUGNANT THAT YOU SUPPORT, BUT
I'M NOT -- IS IT OKAY TO SCREAM
AT NANCY PELOSI UNTIL SHE LEAVES
A RESTAURANT?
THE ANSWER IS NO, IT IS NOT
OKAY, IT IS NEVER OKAY.
>> SHE WAS WALKING ON A
FUND-RAISER THE OTHER DAY -- YOU
DON'T SEE ANY OF US --
>> Tucker: IF I SAID
NANCY PELOSI, I WILL YELL AT YOU
UNTIL YOU LEAVE BECAUSE YOU
SUPPORT A POLICY I DISAGREE
WITH, I THINK A NORMAL PERSON
WOULD SAY --
>> THAT IS NOT WHAT HAPPENED --
IN THE LAST TEN DAYS,
DONALD TRUMP USE THE NAME GEORGE
SOROS FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HIS
PRESIDENCY, AND THE GUY HAD A
PIPE BOMB IN HIS MAILBOX LAST
NIGHT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT SARAH SANDERS GETS HER --
YOU THINK IT IS A COINCIDENCE?
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP RUNS
AROUND --
>> Tucker: I'M LAUGHING
BECAUSE -- I HAVE CRITICIZED
SOROS A THOUSAND TIMES.
>> BUT I'M NOT DONALD TRUMP.
>> Tucker: ELECTED LEADERS ARE
NOT ALLOWED TO CRITICIZE GEORGE
SOROS?
>> IF THERE IS AN ANGRY MOB --
IF WE HAD GONE FROM COCONUT
JUICE AND SOY TO ANGRY MOB, AND
EVERYONE IS SO WORRIED ABOUT
VIOLENCE, WHY HAS DONALD TRUMP
NOT SAID, EVERYONE NEEDS TO DIAL
IT DOWN?
THE RHETORIC IN OUR SOCIETY
RIGHT NOW -- HE HAS NEVER SAID
IT, TUCKER.
HE CALLED THE DEMOCRATS AN ANGRY
MOB.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE AN ANGRY
>> IT IS CATCHY.